mais là tu sors avec quoi maintenant un
comptable
owen un ventriloque et amoureuse
d'important on n'est pas là pour ça
depuis
je sais pourquoi on est là
ok
une mission de sauvetage sauver les
dinosaures de lille qui est sur le point
d'exploser
qu'est ce qu'on risque blue est vivante
du liveview
ces animaux méritent ils d'être protégés
comme les autres espèces vous faut-il
les laisser mourir
ces créatures étaient là bien avant nous
si on n'y prend pas garde
ils seront encore là bien après
tu connais
pour elle
quoi
ouais
[Musique]
la vie ne peut pas être contenu la vie
prend le large
la vie trouve toujours un chemin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]